I'm here with Jarrod Parkes who
is a course developer at Udacity.
Thank you so much for
talking to us today, Jarrod.
>> Thanks for having me.
>> We're going to talk a little
bit about student isolation, and
especially student isolation as
it arises in online classes.
I wanted to talk to Jarrod about this,
because, Jarrod,
you have unique experience in three
different ways on this topic.
One is as the student of online classes.
One is as the designer
of online classes.
And one is also as a remote employee.
Jarrod works for
Udacity in Mountain View, but
actually works out of
his home in Alabama.
So that's kind of three interesting
takes on the angle of isolation.
So let's start with the class, with
the experience as a student in a class.
So what's your experience
being a student in
an online class where you might not be
colocated with your fellow students?
>> So every time that I've taken an
online class, I think one of the things
I quickly find myself doing is wanting
to share my experience with people.
So whether I'm taking the class in
isolation, which is usually the case.
When I'm done with whatever the lesson
is that day, or the content that I've
consumed, very quickly I want to
talk with other people about it.
So for me,
I've always been able, luckily,
to facilitate that with actual
in-person conversations.
But I think for others, it's useful
to have a place to discuss topics.
>> So is that a perspective you try and
incorporate when you're
designing courses?
>> Is there a way we can
>> Absolutely.
>> facilitate that?
I think any and every opportunity that
we have and that students want to take
advantage of that is discussion-based,
it's always beneficial.
I mean, that really, I think,
helps capture what is difficult
sometimes in the online education space,
is that you don't have the same physical
classroom that's traditionally always
been there, where people are having
these types of conversations.
>> It's true that there's an absence
of that physical interaction,
that face-to-face interaction
that we have right here.
But, in your experience, is there any
instance where not only can the online
environment be as good as it might be
in person, but can it ever be better?
>> I think so.
I think what the online environment
has allowed me to do personally, and
I think maybe some others as well,
is that it allows me to put my head down
and just go straight into a topic and
not have to weed through, say,
the conversation sometimes.
So it's kind of
a mix-and-match approach.
And, yeah,
when I want to learn a certain topic,
I can go and find it freely.
And I think that's something that
is better inherently about it.
>> Yeah.
I think that one of my favorite
experiences with isolation in an online
classroom and the comparison to
an on-campus class is that on campus,
if I know there's a student question
coming up, or I know students
are confused about something, and it's,
you know, Friday night, and I just
finished a lecture on Friday afternoon,
and I'm aware that
students are confused,
I have to wait until Monday to get back
to them and talk to them about that.
But what we have online is
what I call 24/7 classroom.
It's always there.
Students are always
available to interact,
since they're always
checking their email.
They can always visit forums.
They always have a way that they
can interact with one another.
As I mentioned this before in these
interviews, but I can have an experience
where I'll log into our class forum and
in five minutes I can interact with ten
different students and then come
back an hour later and do it again.
And that's something we
can't really do in person.
In person, we have this time box thing
and we have limited resources to meet in
person because we have different
classes and things like that.
So there's a lot of things that we
can do online that actually can
break that isolation.
But to your point, it's not something
that just happens automatically.
>> Right.
>> It's something, yeah.
>> And it's interesting.
It's kind of like a dichotic state.
I think students have moments in their
learning where they really want to be
in conversation,
and then they have moments in their
learning where they really don't.
And I think a lot of times as
you're taking online courses,
a lot of that responsibility is
being placed on you as the learner.
And I think for us as course designers,
if we can take some of that
responsibility away and facilitate the
times when you want to learn with your
head down to the grindstone or
when you want to have class discussion.
>> Yeah, that need's really nice, too,
because I sometimes comment on what I
call a rule of 20s, which is if anything
is effective for 20% of the students in
a class, we should use it,
because 20% is a decent enough portion.
But we're never going to
have anything reach 100%.
And that's really nice here, because it
means that those 20% who are, or more,
who are going to get a lot out of
class discussions can do them.
But those who really don't
get a lot out of them don't
have to sit in the classroom
listening to them.
>> Right.
And,
I mean, I think a lot of students
experience this at an early age, for
instance, in traditional classrooms
where the conversation is something
you already know.
A lot of people enter a grade
school at very different levels.
And so if you don't skip a grade or you
don't get into the accelerated program,
you get bored, and
that's not good for students.
>> That's a waste of time.
And I think that students learn over
time that if I'm not consistently
being challenged, that school is boring.
And that's definitely not
what we want them to learn,
because eventually
school won't be boring.
Eventually, you know, they'll get to
the level that they're ready for.
But we don't want them to have learned
that they can skate through until then.
>> Right.
>> So
come tell a little bit
about your experience,
if you don't mind, also as a pay remote
employee, someone working at a distance.
Is there a similarity between being
a remote student and a remote employee?
>> I think there are similarities in the
fact that I feel like I need discussion
as a remote employee, whether that's
facilitated through online chat or
if I can just talk to a friend.
So, you know,
where I work from in Alabama,
I try to do my best to create
a space that is kind of the office
that's very separate
from what is the home.
And then I've also tried to force
myself during the day to go out and
have conversations with people,
even if it's just over lunch,
because if I don't do that,
I feel like I've been in a cave all day.
And it drives motivation down.
The same kind of motivation maybe it is
for learning, I feel like it drives my
motivation down for producing good
material and doing good work.
>> I think nowadays we also are,
have the benefit of a lot of really nice
tools around these programs
that we have, our class forums.
I know that the OMSCS
program uses HipChat.
We at EDSC use Slack.
And there are some really nice
tools that can kind of try and
to recreate that environment of being
in an office or being in a classroom.
That I always have people at my
fingertips that I can talk to or
I can always post a message right
now while I'm thinking about it that
people will see when they have time,
as opposed to, oh,
I need to remember to bring that up on
Monday when I get back to class, so.
>> Yeah, it's one of those,
it's like that strange,
or it's strange,
it's like the old saying, you know,
you don't know how much you
miss something until it's gone.
And when you're in the office every day
around tons of people and maybe you have
too many meetings, you're like, gosh, I
wish I didn't have to meet all the time,
whereas when I'm remote, I feel like I
look forward to the meetings because
that's my opportunity to actually get
to talk to somebody during the day.
>> Yeah.
Absolutely.
So do you have any final thoughts for
our students who might be trying to
solve the problem of student isolation
when they're designing their tools?
>> I think it's just to be conscientious
of the things we just talked about, and
to recognize that, you know,
maybe when your motivation is down and
you feel isolated, to go out and
seek and speak with other students.
You never know what
you're going to learn.
And I think there's a lot of
reciprocity between what happens
in student conversations a lot.
I mean, you're going to get
something out of it and
somebody that you're speaking with
is going to get something out of it.
>> Okay.
Makes a lot of sense to me.
Great.
Thank you so much for
talking to us today.